Jeopardy's one I guess more Emmys than
any other quiz show over the years very
very long tradition what's changed in
terms of the technology that you've used
on the show over the years oh gosh if
you're too young to remember the
original jeopardy program which aired
from 1964 to 74 they would reveal the
categories and the clues by hand and
occasionally you would see the person's
hand the technicians hand in the shot
raising the card to reveal the clue then
we went to computers and since I took
over in 1984 we have added more and more
technology each year we've got video
clues audio Clues we have hired four
very bright people the clue crew who
traveled around the world to record
clues for us I graduated from the
University of Southern California little
over three years ago and since then I've
been pursuing my dream as a television
journalist unfortunately its what I'm
about to do here
there are probably other businesses that
use the Internet as much as we do but I
don't know what they are so how did you
manage before the internet you know back
in the dark ages it's hard to it's hard
to even ever remember but I'll tell you
I'll give an example back in the old old
old days they writers and researchers
used to have they only worked four days
a week in the office and one day was
called a library day and they all went
to the library so now that there's an
internet you all get Friday's off you
know now my favorite category ever wrote
is one I came up with the idea of what
if dr. Seuss had written Shakespeare and
I called it dr. Seuss meets the bard and
what I did was wrote I wrote Clues as if
someone in a famous play were talking
but he it was in the language of
something that dr. Seuss would have
written dr. Seuss meets the bar Kiss Me
Kate though you're a meanie
now eeny you can see our brand
new set which reflects the latest
technology that Sony has we have flat
screens were into High Definition in a
few years I'm sure we'll be doing
three-dimensional television also and
during the transition to HD
were there any were there any snags or
was it was it a smooth process I mean
that's a major overhaul right of
equipment and everything well it wasn't
a big problem for me because it didn't
change my hosting activity although one
thing I did notice was that I look
better in high-def channel television
than I did before
we went out and found the best HD makeup
consultants that we could find and what
we learned is that whereas you would
think that because the camera is so
unforgiving that the makeup should be
thicker to cover any flaws it's just the
opposite
the makeup is applied with airbrushing
you're kidding me
well that's technology right there yeah
so it's a very fine mist and and it
makes for a much much much softer look
it is easier now for people to try out
for the program because they can do it
on the internet and in terms of the
viewers while the technology has moved
out so far now that you can pick up your
cell phone and you can play jeopardy
while it airs in any city in America or
in Canada and it gives you a choice of
three possible responses and if you're
really fast you get to punch in and if
you do it ahead of the contestants
you'll wind up winning prizes
do I look nervous about drugs